tony kennett is the science coordinator
at the indianapolis public schools
district in indiana and he's also the
founder of chalkboard review you may
have seen his video making the rounds on
the internet today in the video kenneth
responds to claims from democrats that
critical race theory isn't taught in
schools watch
we do have critical race theory in how
we teach we tell our teachers to treat
students differently based on color we
tell our students that every problem is
a result of white men and that
everything western civilization built is
racist capitalism as a tool of white
supremacy those are straight out of
kimberly crenshaw's main points verbatim
in critical race theory the writings
that formed the movement
this is in math history science english
the arts and it's not slowing down
tony kenneth joins us now so you're
saying the dodge is
yeah they don't have
crt 101 after math class but what they
do have is the entire crt
infused in every single course in every
single classroom throughout the
curriculum is that right
absolutely there's this very clever
trick that a lot of administrators will
pull in education there are two things
that consist of learning we have
curriculum which is what the students
are learning and then we have pedagogy
which is how it's taught so we can
officially tell parents we're not
teaching critical race theory it's not
in the indiana academic standards but
all of a sudden the classroom door shuts
and the teacher starts teaching through
a lens of this race essentialism that
pits students against each other based
on their color
so give some advice to parents out there
perhaps they don't know if crt is in the
school that their kids are going to how
would they go about discovering it and
if it is infected
in the school district there where they
live what's their next step
well the first thing you should really
be doing is talking to your kids
teachers so many of my parents had great
conversations with me weekly on what was
going on not just inside my classroom
but inside the school there is this very
interesting myth by the left that all of
the teachers are on the left and the
right believes it a lot of teachers
really just want to go in and teach and
they are happy to have discussions with
parents however if you find that a
teacher is being uncooperative they're
teaching things that
really shouldn't be taught in a
classroom they're treating your kid
different based on a color you have a
responsibility to go to the principal
then to the superintendent and if that
doesn't work you really should look into
electing a much better school board
that's going to serve your community
based on merit not on color what kind of
damage to the child's brain does
something like crt do
oh it's horrific you get into high
school courses where a teacher will open
things up for discussion and we see this
in english classes a lot they'll talk
about a piece of poetry they'll talk
about something that a writer has
brought to bear and then the teacher
will portray it through a societal lens
like critical race theory and then
provide this orwellian two minutes of
hate and the students will be expected
to talk about things in the essay or in
cases in like manhattan students will be
expected to say things from home that
were brought up in a very racist way and
all of the students are expected to
participate in this to chip in a little
bit of progressive ideology and it gets
really sketchy really quickly for a kid
that doesn't buy into the rest of the
stuff and they don't do this in math do
they they can't bring
crt into math can they
oh they sure can they sure can
ethnomathematics is a huge thing that's
coming to indianapolis public schools we
just had a very large meeting about it
and there's actually a program that's
being developed with indiana university
that would analyze how a teacher teaches
analyze the scores of the students and
then determine how racist a teacher is
in teaching that math course
ethno mathematics i haven't heard that
one before
thank you so much tony that was that was
eye opening we appreciate it
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else